la bibliothèque départementale de la
réunion inaugure sa toute nouvelle
exposition
elle met à l'honneur gaston monnerville
un homme politique français originaire
de guyane
ce petit fils d'esclave commence sa
carrière comme avocat et très vite
s'engage en politique c'est finalement
l'homme des colonies l'homme des dom tom
qui a eu les plus hautes fonctions au
sein de la république et qui est très
très peu connu et surtout de la nouvelle
génération
donc voilà le but c'est que notamment
les jeunes de nos lycées de nos collèges
puissent se dire oui il ya eu un enfant
des dom tom
un enfant de la république qui a accédé
aux fonctions les pelotons numéro deux
de l'état derrière le président de
république président du sénat pendant 22
ans et un parcours exceptionnel qui fera
que gaston monnerville oeuvre aura à la
départementalisation des quatre vieilles
colonies de la france en 1946 la
guadeloupe la guyane la martinique et la
réunion de vienne des départements
d'outre-mer de la départementalisation
donc nous avions depuis longtemps voulu
montrer aux jeunes réunionnais puisque
nous faisons donc de l'éducation
citoyenne laïque et civique dans les
pavillons scolaire un parcours de
réussite d'un enfant métisse puisque
c'est aussi nous sommes au mois de mars
et c'est aussi là 21 mars est la journée
internationale de lutte contre le
racisme
donc pour montrer aux jeunes un parcours
de réussite où tout est possible
un précurseur des îles investi en
politique au plus haut niveau et qui
représente donc les îles et on fait
aussi le 70e anniversaire de la
départementalisation donc quoi de mieux
que de faire honneur à quelques uns des
îles qui a marqué son temps dans la
politique et dans toutes les avancées
qu'on a connus depuis l'exposition
gaston monnerville combat pour les
libertés est ouverte au public du 9 mars
au 9 avril à la bibliothèque
départementale de la réunion le public
pourra découvrir l'histoire de cet homme
engagé qui aura défendu les libertés et
oeuvrer à la départementalisation des
autres maires des goûts des jeux je le
laissais évidemment gaston monnerville
pas forcément dans le détail donc déjà
cette exposition permet d'en savoir
beaucoup plus long sur sa vie son sa
personnalité ce qu'il a apporté à notre
pays est si régulièrement au département
futur département d'outre-mer je trouve
extrêmement bien faite et arrivant à
point nommé puisque nous célébrons le
70e anniversaire de la
départementalisation